[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio en las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos de este caso colombia lleva
días movilizada en las calles y también
en internet y redes sociales los
ciudadanos que protestan las utilizan
para difundir su versión de los hechos
que con frecuencia no reflejan los
medios tradicionales para organizarse y
hacer denuncias en especial sobre la
violencia policial el saldo de las
protestas es de entre 26 y 37 muertos
dependiendo de las fuentes empezamos
como en 2019 los colombianos han vuelto
masivamente a las calles en un paro
nacional esta vez contra un alza de
impuestos y el ministro que la diseñó la
primera fue retirada por el gobierno y
el segundo dimitió pero las
movilizaciones continúan motivadas por
profundos reclamos sociales y por la
indignación ante la violenta respuesta
del estado en redes sociales los
usuarios han venido publicando lo que
sucede en las calles desde
concentraciones y marchas masivas así
como plantones y performances hasta los
desmanes protagonizados por minorías que
son manifestantes
o muchos creen infiltrados de la policía
que han incendiado autobuses o que hay
pequeñas estaciones de policía que hay
en todos los barrios la defensoría del
pueblo registró 26 homicidios en el
marco de las protestas mientras que las
ong dicen que son más de 30 muertos por
presunta violencia policial cientos de
personas han sido detenidas y hay
denuncias de desapariciones la
desconfianza en los medios de
comunicación colombianos lleva a los
manifestantes a transmitir sus denuncias
en vivo en las redes sociales
celebridades nacionales e
internacionales organizaciones como la
onu y gobiernos o instituciones como la
unión europea se han sumado a las
críticas contra el uso excesivo de la
fuerza por parte de las autoridades
directo 'live un caso en particular está
en el centro de la polémica lucas biglia
un joven que fue baleado por
desconocidos en la ciudad de pereira
mientras protestaba pacíficamente la
noche del 6 de mayo lucas recibió ocho
impactos de bala mientras era parte de
una protesta pacífica vídeos de él
bailando entre la multitud de sus
llamados a la no violencia y del momento
en que fue atacado sean viralizado
inicialmente se reportó su
que generó indignación pero el hospital
a donde fue llevado afirmó que había
ingresado a una unidad de cuidados
intensivos y que se encontraba en estado
crítico al momento de grabar este
programa denuncias sobre víctimas como
lucas biglia invaden las redes sociales
en colombia por estos días pero también
diversas y creativas formas de protesta
para hacerle saber al mundo la situación
que atraviesa el país el chat de las
transmisiones que naciones unidas hace
en youtube se ha visto inundado por
miles de personas que escriben
repetidamente ese o ese colombia en
redes sociales un gran número de
usuarios han cambiado su foto de perfil
por una bandera con los colores
invertidos un sinónimo de descontento
que algunas publicaciones en internet en
colombia sugieren errónea pero elocuente
mente que es una señal de auxilio
estipulada en la carta de las naciones
unidas fotos y vídeos con el título que
está pasando en colombia han sido
replicados por celebridades
internacionales como demi lovato y viola
davis vídeos como este en cali tercera
ciudad del país y epicentro de las
protestas de la violencia policial que
denuncian que policías encubiertos de
civil estarían disparando contra
manifestantes se publican constantemente
varias de estas publicaciones
tendencia en colombia durante días
internet ha sido también un campo de
batalla entre denuncias de censura y
operaciones de hackeo contra sitios
oficiales el 5 de mayo en cali usuarios
denunciaron una caída de internet
confirmada por la ong en netbooks que
vigila la libertad de acceso a internet
en el mundo el ministerio a cargo adujo
una falla en un operador de red
subterránea la mañana del 6 de mayo de
usuarios de instagram se dieron cuenta
de que la mayoría de las historias que
habían publicado la noche anterior sobre
las protestas habían desaparecido
denunciaron también que el número de
visualizaciones era más reducido en las
publicaciones referentes a las protestas
a raíz de las múltiples quejas y en una
serie de comunicados instagram respondió
a lo siguiente este es un problema
técnico global generalizado que no está
relacionado con ningún tema en
particular y lo estamos solucionando
ahora mismo nos disculpamos con todos
los afectados especialmente con los que
crean conciencia sobre causas
importantes a nivel mundial sin embargo
según dijeron usuarios de países vecinos
donde france24 verificó el problema no
se presentó en sus territorios si los
manifestantes se han sentido censurados
también han tenido apoyo
el colectivo de ciberactivistas anónimos
reapareció declarando la guerra al
gobierno colombiano con una serie de
ataques anónimos dio de baja
temporalmente a las páginas web del
ejército el senado y la presidencia
publicó una lista con correos y
contraseñas de militares y algunos
congresistas se dijo haber interceptado
las comunicaciones de radio de la
policía aunque esta institución lo negó
y hasta publicó el número celular del
comandante del ejército a lo que matador
un célebre caricaturista local crítico
del gobierno respondió diciendo que de
ese número había recibido mensajes
ofensivos ahora veamos cómo los medios
internacionales han registrado esta
situación empezamos en la región el
diario el comercio de ecuador dice que
las protestas en colombia se mantienen
vivas al grito de no más violencia folk
ya de sao paulo en brasil dice colombia
ve crecer la crítica internacional en
medio de muertos y desaparecidos en
protestas el 'new york times' la policía
de colombia responde a las protestas con
balas y el número de muertos aumentan te
vamos a europa el país de españa dice
que la violencia policial se descontrola
en colombia en francia el periódico le
monde
colombia tras una semana de represión
policial nuevas manifestaciones denuncia
las políticas del gobierno y bajo el
título disturbios en colombia comparte
tus experiencias el sitio web británico
'the guardian' habilitó un espacio para
que a través de la página o por medio de
una cuenta de whatsapp los colombianos
hagan sus denuncias
hasta aquella revista digital recuerda
que se quiere repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
punto frente 4 puntocom
[Música]